a bride without Hina and India would be
probably like not even accepted it has
been an old saying in the tradition that
the darker the color is and the more
love you get from your in-laws what I
also like about henna is brings in more
feminine side and no elegant side of a
woman in it when this figurine title
came in front of me I had to get it it
gives you a good edge over the regular
dressing up getting this figurine a hyna
is a little more expensive than the
usual ones but then who cares about the
price when I get such beautiful
detailing intricate work on my hands
but yeah it was a little tiring the
results are like wonderful it looks so
pretty it looks so exquisite on my hands
makes me feel like a walking piece of
art all together